At every point of our fluid we have a velocity, but also we have pressure.
Velocity has direction. Pressure doesn't.
Now let's try to find out how to incorporate pressure in our equations.
To make things simple, we look at a one-dimensional situation--
a straight pipe filled with fluid.
Capital a is the cross-section area of that pipe.
Let's replace some amount of that fluid with the piston of width Δx,
and let's assume that the pressure to the left of that piston is p₁
and the pressure to the right of that piston is p₂.
Then this force is proportional to the difference of those two pressures.
If p₁, the pressure on the left, is larger than p₂, the pressure on the right,
the force is to the right.
So we have to choose sides like that.
The proportionality constant is simply the area.
If you double the area, you double the force.
If we say that this piston has a volume of v,
then the area, of course, is the volume of the piston divided by its width.
If we want to use this as part of our differential equations, what should we be writing?
What's the force per volume?
The partial derivative of pressure with respect to x?
Minus the partial derivative of the pressure with respect to x?
Half the partial derivative or the pressure divided by the square root of the area?